[Music]
flowers come not only in a variety of
shapes but also in a variety of types
have a look at these flasks for example
aren't these beautiful masterpieces
different from the conventional ones
that we usually glance at yes and since
they are totally different this type of
arrangement is given a special name as
well such an arrangement of a cluster of
flowers on a stem is called
inflorescence let's understand this
beautiful concept in detail can you help
me with the definition to begin with
what exactly is inflorescence that's
right we would prefer taking an example
let's take the same flower as we can see
here there is no single flower at the
apex of the stem rather small flowers
cluster and form a complete structure
although this is not the perfect analogy
but just to understand we can relate
this to the pinnately compound leaves
remember their structure yes this is how
they appear as the small leaflets
arrange themselves and give us this
complete structure
similarly here these small flowers make
up the complete inflorescence please
note that the pinnately compound leaves
and inflorescence are just considered to
understand that concept better we are
neither comparing nor relating the two
getting back to our concept the flowers
form a group along the stem or at the
apex to form the inflorescence now tell
me will the structure of the flowers at
Apex form an inflorescence or along the
stem
I mean will this be called as
inflorescence or this to our
astonishment both of these are in
fluorescence let's understand these
types in detail the first type is where
the flowers are arranged laterally along
the central axis the
most important point to note here is
that the apex or the terminal point of
the chute does not bear a flower that
means it can freely grow indefinitely
such a type is called Ray cymose
inflorescence here the arrangement of
the flowers is alongside the central
axis leaving the apex free in this type
the older flowers are found near the
base while the newer ones start
developing towards the apex
now since the apex can grow continuously
and indefinitely this type is also
called as indefinite inflorescence so
can you guess what could the next type
be that's right it will be the opposite
of this does it will be definite
inflorescence
the type we see in this case as we can
see here apart from the ones along the
central axis a flower even develops at
the apex as a result the growth of the
chute does not occur indefinitely as in
the first case this type is called the
cymose inflorescence as we can see here
the apex is occupied by the older
flowers while the newer ones start
shooting from the secondary branches
that are formed so this type has older
ones at the apex and the newer flowers
at the base in contrast to the racer
most inflorescence to summarize we find
these flowers exhibiting ray Simoes and
these exhibiting cymose inflorescence
this typical patterns of arrangement
help us study the plant in many ways
[Music]